ever since so we just went through a
emergency 50 basis point rate cut I saw
a guy on television I forget his name
yesterday literally saying in the next
two weeks we could be at zero which
seems a little aggressive where do we go
from here
well look we were pricing in a recession
and now we're pricing in something else
so it's gone faster than we've expected
so this is and that's because your
argument is the economic kind of macro
situation was slowing everything you'd
been talking about it was going to be a
recession coming right global creates a
Laurent you get an accelerant with the
krona fall we had two accelerants right
so we had the Fed raising rates back in
2017 and they've gone too far so you saw
it because you start seeing the curve
inverting start see all of this signs
that the Fed agon so far which was
extraordinary because they barely raise
rates but that was the situation so that
was the slowdown that was set then we
had trade war so trade war and tariffs
that was the kindling for the recession
so that's the recession we were gonna
get and then the coronavirus comes and
now we're gonna have something entirely
different
where do you think we're going right
it's therefore not yet if we're not
getting a recession what is it you know
the answer that's why you're asking so
listen the reason why I'm so excited to
have you here is because you have become
you know what a storm chaser is like a
tornado chaser right well yeah they go
and they try to find the tornadoes and
they're the the psychos that are driving
on the road and they're filming the
tornado to me you're a crisis chaser
right meaning that it's not that you
want a crisis now because a lot of
people get hurt and it's really bad
situation but you have the clarity to
see them coming and we've also lived
calls and I'm seeing them before and I
know
so the point bear the crisis chaser yeah
the point being is it's about human
behavior it's not about what's right
what's wrong and it's not about
how you should interpret if the numbers
Rock nothing it's like when it comes to
a crisis whether it was the Asian crisis
whether it was the bond market crisis in
94 the Asian crisis in 97 the dot-com
bust or the banking crisis they're all
human behavior and once you understand
that humans were about to panic it's
when everything moves fast yeah and I
think that if you are a good investor
you actually slow down right you you you
don't have to get caught up in that
panic it's like having the emotional
defense there was soup really what I did
in this situation and I did in all the
other situations was I doubled up ahead
of the panic when I saw that it was
likely to lead to a panic because my job
is not to live in the present it's
everybody makes the mistake of living in
the present saying oh the virus numbers
today are X that is not what you're
doing you have to extrapolate and you
have to think of possible futures of
which you don't know there are no
certainties but it's extrapolating
positive futures when you see a path of
events that it seems much more probable
than the market expects and you can see
a clearer understanding of how people
are going to react to that then you have
something really meaty with this
situation it was clear that the moment
the virus spread outside China it was
clear that China had gone into total
shutdown
okay that was we've never seen that in
our lifetimes anywhere in any country so
this isn't this is important let's talk
about exactly oh that's a lot to talk
about and so there's a virus the Chinese
government gets wind of hey this is
spreading this is a problem and there's
a couple of different ways to look at
how they've reacted there's the kind of
medical reaction so this is where you
see quarantines and a building of
hospitals and kind stuff but the
economic impact of a lot of this is
literally they just went into complete
shutdown nobody go anywhere do and yes
so the idea is if you've got a really
bad outbreak of a unknown virus you can
either take the risk
and have mass death even with a death
rate the w-h-o today's so it's three and
a half percent so with a population size
of China's and it's an aging population
and it affects old people more that is
too much for the government to deal with
and you have unknowns because you don't
know the death rate at that point you
don't know the spread rate what they
clearly knew is spreading fast very fast
so I think what's known as the RO or the
R was above anything from the common flu
to the Spanish flu to any of the known
pandemics so they knew that it was
extremely dangerous hence why you go to
the carnival canonic lockdown which is
to quarantine that Pop's parts of the
population because the weird part of
this virus is it's not detectable for
two weeks and up to twenty seven days so
we can all have it here and we have no
symptoms and we're spreading it around
and we don't know right that is like a
nuclear [ __ ] warhead right you you
have no idea you have one of the fastest
spreading viruses we know of and it's
undetectable and it has a high death
rate even though people say oh that's
not a very high death rate when you
actually impute the numbers that it's a
staggering number of people that could
die but the numbers that I looked at
this morning basically anyway I think is
1840 or something was the bucket that
they showed the flu death rate is 0.02
percent and the coronavirus death rate
is point two so literally a 10 acts now
it's still 20 basis points but when you
start to look at that and again it's
still scary don't think about the death
rate because everyone will say well it's
not that relevant isn't 2 percent or 3
and a half percent and only affects old
people's not gonna fit me there's no
economic impact it it's the fact that
when you acute the numbers that it
spreads fast in the Spanish flu but
let's assume it reached the same number
of people as the Spanish flu let's
assume nobody quarantines countries like
China which was the right thing today
then Spanish flu hit 27 percent of the
entire worlds population and at the time
that meant 500 million people were
infected and in the end about 30 million
people died
okay if you look at 27% of population
now it's about two billion people if you
have a death rate for in half cents 68
million people will die
so that's your base worst case scenario
so then that's what you have but that's
the outcome if you don't do anything so
every government is going to do
everything they can because also it
disproportionately affects Western
developments why because your old
populations all of us right so you have
a a significant problem also old
populations who get a virus I mean the
death rate of people who go into
hospital is huge in this virus and
there's a large hundred people African
Hospital we have no ability to deal with
this in the medical system so they have
no choice but to start quarantine
Ignatians or at least large regions
which has a ridiculous economic impact
in terms of the slowdown but number like
talk a little bit about the numbers that
came out of China the user I mean China
car sales fell 92 percent and this month
they're down 80 something percent we
well that's [ __ ] wild but I mean the
PMI the Purchasing Managers Index for
for China had the largest fall I've ever
seen in any economic statistic I've ever
seen and that is in the second largest
economy on earth with the largest
population it is mind-blowing and no one
of the oil prices collapse no wonder all
of these things are happening and that's
just China
the point being to all of this is next
it was South Korea South Korea is a
great medical system and they were on
top of it fast they're slowing the rate
of the virus there but they still got
thousands of people affected and the
death rate is climbing and it's not
going to go and then it spread
regionally but then the next big cluster
was Italy Italy exploded and it's still
going because they're still I mean this
bloody flights every 10 minutes from
malpensa
are you crazy it's now exploding in
Spain France Germany Iran if Iran was a
truly extraordinary because it was a
different strain they didn't know that
it come from China whether it had come
from China and it I mean literally 10%
of all government officials are infected
50 percent or 20 percent of the entire
government is ill so crazy so back that
out to what is about to happen right
what's interesting is South Korea is
testing thousands of people a day to get
on top of where it is where it's moving
what we have to who we need quarantine
the u.s. up until last Friday had tested
500 people and they had only tested
people that had come from China or Japan
or a country that had the virus and I
think this is where we get Washington
State there was the outbreak and kind of
a whole group of people have now tested
positive they all are circulating either
they worked at our patients at or I
guess live at this nursing home and I
was reading this morning that in Wake
County North Carolina actually where I'm
from there's a coronavirus confirmation
case and you start reading about well
how how does that happen
the person went and literally went to
that nursing home a couple of weeks ago
comes back to the point being a couple
of weeks ago mm-hmm right you know this
it's very clear that the corona virus
has been spreading undetected and
unabated in the United States for at
least three weeks
there was a weird ridiculous situation
where the CDC and the FDA gotten some
regulatory mess where it got declared a
national emergency which meant that that
only the CDC could do testing with CDC
approved equipment of which it was only
one place in Atlanta to do it they
eventually got it out to 40 different
places eventually but no testing went
ahead because the kits were not approved
and there were some malfunctions with
the kid so there's been no testing in
America so nurses and doctors and health
care workers have been treating people
without taking precautions there is no
tracking of pneumonia cases yet because
they're usually now they're most likely
to be corona virus cases so the point
being is when you look forward and Boris
Johnson was good yesterday in the UK
when he said listen 80% of the
population could get this you know and
this is going to be huge and we're gonna
have to we may have to shut down the
entire country and he's right to get the
narrative that far that fast to get
people to understand the seriousness of
it because in the US people don't even
understand this they're still going it's
the flu no it's not the flu the size of
it and speed the speed at which it
spreads and the incremental increase in
deaths worldwide is not something a
government will take so they're going to
have to close large parts of the economy
and people nobody's going to fly and
this will be the last flyer takes the
flying car back to the Cayman Islands
and I think the Cayman Islands will shut
and I've already been speaking turd here
some of the doctors there and blah blah
blah we haven't any cases yet but they
know it's going to shut yeah so when
that happens if it's not a recession if
it's something worse yeah so it look the
clear thing is we were going to a
recession could have been a mild one
could have been a big one we don't
really know where we're going to
recession this just pressed the nuclear
button for depression now I say that not
lightly there is always a probability
that it doesn't happen but it's become
my base case now because I do not see a
world in which there is not an outcome
that I have to share
down whole parts of economies whether
that's travel tourism conferences
businesses all of this stuff we're
already seeing it is there it's already
starting to happen or ever seeing
conferences get canceled we're seeing
obvious slowdowns in travel and tourism
weight when they quarantine people at
home you know it's not long before you
guys are going to be at home doing this
self quarantined it's gonna happen
because you're going to want to do that
for your own sake and you don't to be
part of the spread of the virus you know
because it's gonna be your mother or
grandmother that gets killed so your
argument here is the virus itself is
simply an accelerant on a situation that
was already turning bad right in the
economic kind of recessionary period and
now what we're gonna do is we're
actually going to extend that into an
actual depression and really its lower
again I don't deal in certainties but
I'm saying that the the probability the
highest probability of n now is a much
larger event and I think potentially my
base case is becoming and we have to see
over the next four weeks my base case is
coming that this will be the worst
economic event of our lifetimes so this
is much larger than 2008